[Music]
[Applause]
I think all of us together couldn't
tackle our next guest but I'd like to
try he's a former MVP now he has a great
show it's Cam's YouTube channel it's
called fourth in one say hello to the
former NFL MVP Cam
Newton
how we doing how we doing how we doing
can we get a shot of the back of the
shirt Game Changer game manager that's
fantastic I like that all right might as
well there you go yeah Game Changer game
manager how much do you spend on clothes
each year uh I Thrift you do I'm a Avid
thrift shopper I like that uh figured
out a long time time ago I've made a lot
of people money and I only wear once so
I figured if I just take that same
metrics and and spend cheaper coin on it
okay I won't feel so bad but plus when
you wear it certain people when they
wear something it just looks better so
people would think you spent a lot of
money and you you probably didn't you
just kind of piece it all together
almost all this was given outside of
the yeah yeah okay all right uh the last
time I think you were with us this was
uh Arizona and uh you look at that
picture uh I think we have you here look
at that kid look at that look at clean
cut who is it like are you that's a guy
you could take home Tom mom you good
it's like a picture day what about this
guy though take them home to your
grandma did you ever want to act uh no
sir I I think behind the
scenes I had more enjoyment in in kind
of doing um but the level of commitment
and my girlfriend she's an actor so it's
like I see what she does and I'm like
nah that's not me there's so much
downtime on a movie set right and cuz
I've done a lot of Sandler movies and
you're there and then you wait you could
wait 6 7even hours sure and then you do
60 to 90 seconds on camera and then your
day is done couldn't do it too boring
yeah I could say the same yeah and but
the call times are are what you're
speaking on is is a long time but when
you think about acting not it's not the
acting per se but reciting lines is kind
of similar to what quarterbacks do
anyway when you get a Playbook you have
to be able to recited very Ecentric and
and to the te you got memorize you have
to memorize it right so it's kind of
similar but not you're not acting you
know but uh you have to recite Lin but
have you acted when you played to try to
draw you know a
penalty like flop there no you never
flopped you never like screamed like in
agony when you really a couple times
okay how does that sound though man
listen it's it's a game inside the game
you got to play the game okay but if I'm
official and you get
[Music]
hit murder no that that's too much
that's too much no it's not enough oh
it's not it's not enough I would always
tease the guys you know in the
quarterback uh room anytime I got close
to the sideline and anybody touched me
ball going to wear everything just hands
up whatever but yeah eight years ago
today remember what you were
doing think so I want to forget it but
okay it's still there how about before
the game that feeling of you're going to
play in a Super Bowl right what was it
like I just remember it me
being emotionally
tired it was so much
that it's twice the media twice the
coverage and I just kept thinking to
myself well I just went to the podium
the day before why I got to go back also
the behind the scenes was making sure
your family's here to to take on this
moment that's draining too um social
media was a dynamic as this is now
and Everywhere You Look At that's the
Talk of the Town you can't go anywhere
um plus you were in a smaller Market in
Carolina then you go to the Super Bowl
where everybody's at the Super Bowl
correct correct but I just remember just
being mentally drained you know over
that whole week span and really it's
like two weeks too because you know you
practice well in Carolina we was
practicing that whole week the
excitement of everything and then by the
time you play the game that's just yeah
that's a whole another story okay when
did you know you were in trouble that
Super
Bowl I never thought that we were in
trouble I just figured cuz during that
year we just found ways to win and I
just figured that we were going to find
a way to win it wasn't pretty we didn't
have a lot of pretty games but you know
with with the defense that we did have
with the offensive veterans that we did
have I just felt like we were going to
yearn our way to to a win and it didn't
happen what advice would you give Brock
pie this
week I would tell him uh silence the
noise
and just do what he's been doing I think
we have to stop this narrative that I do
not like Brock parody that's not the
case I'm a fan of Brock par right and
what he's been able to do has been
wowing from a fan as well as a person
who's played this game but I just call
it how I see it and I think what he's
been able to do with getting guys the
football has been something that we've
seen um a lot of people do but not at
this level okay but you're doing your
job but then you could understand how it
would feel on his end or other people
listening that you're you're assessing
his his talent or skill set but he might
view it if if if it's you know he's the
10th best player on his team he is okay
and that's not a that's not a that's
just the truth we have to normalize the
truth yeah you know what I'm saying I
think that's that's where we're having a
problem with digesting in sports in
media and everything it's it's the truth
I I but my a lot of athletes don't tell
the truth correct because they're you
know it's like a Brotherhood here that
quarterback and quarterbacks we don't
criticize each other that's I'm not
criticizing him but it can come across
that way it could from a from an untamed
ear like you would hear that and you be
like oh Kim's bitter no it's no it's not
when you look at the the 49ers rosters
that that uh assessment was garnered
from people saying cam can't be serious
Brock perody is a game Cher and that's
why I'm saying to myself I'm like yo to
be successful you don't always have to
be a game Cher right so
that that kind of transitioned into
another stent where I said Hey in order
to be a game changer you have to be the
top tier of your team right now when I
analyze the roster and I'm saying to
myself I'm like oh okay Fred Warner
Trent wood
Debo
George
CAC you know use that's a lot of guys
but that's not to discredit what Brock
has been able to do and I think having
platforms people take sound bites and
this is a whole oh sure media is full of
sound bites and and the narrative has
always been Cam's just mad that Brock is
doing something I want Brock to win like
I said on my show I don't think the
world is ready for Taylor Swift to
Garner a Super
Bowl what would that look like right man
and and and even even still then it's
like yo I love Travis Kelce this is good
for sports this matchup is great for
sports right
so I'm going have my popcorn ready okay
but game manager maybe if we changed it
to game Commander ER game
CEO game manager I think now okay help
me understand this okay Tom Brady game
manager yes Elite and that's what I said
to me it's a compliment if you know how
to call a game see see it's like
tears right and I think this game has
only had have has only seen four to
potentially five game changers in the
20123 2024 season
right Aaron Rogers
um Lamar Jackson Joe burrow Patrick
Mahomes and Josh Allen okay right that's
five all right so let's look at it
through this
lens Game Changer is at the top sphere
of talent are you
saying Brock per is in that realm no
okay so going back to my first thought
was like like we have to normalize the
truth I'm not this is not not coming
from malice this is not coming from
hatred this is not coming from there's
times where I've said I've held myself
to that same standard I did not play my
best football when I was forced to try
to just be a game changer no cam just be
a game manager CAC is wide open hey Greg
olssen is wide open DJ Mo Steve Smith
these guys are wide just get him the
ball I was not able to do that so the
great ones have that ability to say okay
the game is dictating me to manage the
game okay now when everything is
covered now I have to take it upon
myself to impact the game and that's
what the game changers do
too um are you a Hall of Famer you
ask can now I'm coming again I maybe I
didn't get the answer I wanted last time
no maybe you're trying to just get some
clickbait yes yes I know this that's the
media I know this media I just admire
you listen listen I I admire you so much
and I I I remember having this
conversation and when you when you press
that red button thank you Cam Bloom and
I just talked to my team and I said oh
my God I just went to a school for media
for dummies cuz it was just so concise
there was never like this moment of it
was almost like you got a you had a
bullet in the chamber Bam Bam bam and I
said I got to I got to get my reps up I
got to you know so Dan Patrick
appreciate you to your qu to your
question uh I still the I don't care I I
I I think I what I've been able to do to
this game my presence was felt and
subjective opinions doesn't necessarily
matter to me and that's what really it
comes down you don't think you're going
to look at quarterbacks going in who
played when you played and then go man
man I'm as good as him well there are
some quarterbacks that still playing
that I have that
stain and and and what are their names
again go right oh you just love it but
uh Patrick Mahomes and
just sound bite yeah um but yeah I think
uh what do you do better than Patrick
Mahomes
humbly
nothing and and and I'm you run better
yeah but they don't even you remember
when Patrick messed his knee up yeah
doing a quarterback sneak yeah have we
ever seen him do any just imagine a tush
push with Patrick Mahomes no Andy re boy
hey no it would be so many people
calling for his head right he doesn't
need to do that I think I've seen him
enough to know that they have this very
strategic thing where they shift the uh
tight end Travis Kelce and he will do
the quarterback sneak right we've seen
that right so he's a former quarterback
he is in college and he's got the Sports
World In His Palms right now yeah but do
you envy Travis Kelce
no
man dear United States of
America I would like to say I don't just
say one love for I love people like I
went to school I got my degree in
sociology the study of like I know why
people I'm so enamored of this evolving
or this evolution of who Dan Patrick
that's what I enjoy most right going
back the ESPN prees like all that just
to kind of see how you got to this point
so for me to have any hatred or Envy to
a person no I'm just it's just me trying
to say like less
normalized truth I can't imagine dating
maybe the most famous one of the most
famous people on the
planet right I mean like you know when
Janet Jackson was at her Peak and you're
dating her while you're playing football
wait did you date Janet Jackson while oh
me yeah you I got to stop this y'all got
to stop this no I did not did you date
somebody famous while you were play uh
could I no I know you could yes did you
of course you
could no no everything should not be uh
docu no okay fair enough I just didn't
know if you you dated somebody famous
well I believe answer this question Mr
Patrick all righty going to put me on
the spot here when you talk
about the relationship of Travis Kelsey
and Taylor Swift do you consider Taylor
Swift Travis's girlfriend or
is Travis Taylor's boyfriend Travis is
Taylor's boyfriend hold up hold up say
that again Travis is Taylor's boyfriend
okay so Taylor Swift is the dominant
personality uh I don't know if the
dominant personality but more wide known
say that yeah like when Madonna dated
somebody it was Madonna dating somebody
correct right now Tom Brady with jezelle
that was equal footing it's never equal
it's pretty close it's never equal it's
pretty close as you've married yeah you
know there's times where you have to be
6040 3070 20 80 9010 but
50/50 I strive for 5149
51 good numbers sometimes it's 28 to3
and then I'm trying to come
back come on DP what I didn't I didn't
mention the score in the Super Bowl
against the
Broncos yeah I could have done that you
could have it would have been honest and
I had to I would have had to accept it
right yeah thanks for stopping by thank
you for having me thank you for the live
crowd
too
Elvis and once again yeah Auburn wiggle
Weagle if I can help you with you know
thoughts on your career and how to make
yourself better I'd be more than happy
to help man listen I
am I think Sports as a whole media as a
whole is in this revolutionary time
frame with is a golden air
of athlete generated content I say that
every every time I have a platform to
say it yeah the ones that get it they
get it the ones that don't they just
don't and I'm in the Forefront to say I
don't think me being at ESPN will help
me I think I don't think me being at Fox
will help me that's not that I'm opposed
to those opportunities I'm just saying
I'm a person who's I would love to speak
to you to say like what was the
successes like what's the state of media
right now what's sales right and I see
your questions but also it's a strategy
behind certain things and I think you're
what you're doing now makes more sense
for you I wouldn't put you at ESPN
because it would dilute what you do you
got to make it original you got to make
it you know that people are going to get
that instead of you're on seven shows
you don't want that you want to stand
alone
last question for me okay what's your
true thoughts about Cam
Newton I would I would need more time to
tell you
that I would need more time but that's a
Euro Step out of
that and I'm going to you know what the
next time you're on I would have W Bama
that one and just got get that shot out
of here this guy right here is a dean of
all Deans ladies and gentlemen
by the way it's fourth and one and you
can see more of it it's the YouTube
channel with Cam each and every
Wednesday throughout the season we'll
take a break we'll have Cam judge our uh
our passing form here coming up during
the commercial break and I you'll be
honest of course I know you will we'll
take a break we're back after this